hey this is prestel Walker and you're
watching mind your decisions here's a
fun Math Olympiad practice problem start
with the circle draw a chord with a
length of a then draw a perpendicular
line segment to the interior of the
circle with the length of B then draw a
perpendicular to this line segment with
a length of C it touches the
circumference of the circle the problem
is to solve for the radius R in terms of
a B and C I think Mirza for suggesting
this problem and I admit I did not solve
it so I also think Mirza for sending me
a solution this problem is harder than
it looks
can you figure it out give this problem
a try and when you're ready keep
watching the video for a solution so how
can we solve this problem we're going to
draw in some line segments so that we
can use some well-known properties of
circles first we'll extend this line
segment to a length of a we're then
going to extend it to be a chord of the
circle and by symmetry this line segment
will have a length of C next let's
extend this line segment to be a chord
of the circle we don't know this length
so we'll label it as the variable D now
here's one chord of a circle and here is
another chord of the circle so by power
of a point or the intersecting chords
theorem we have the following expression
B times D is equal to C times the
quantity a plus C we can now use this
formula to solve for the unknown value
of D we divide both sides by B to get
that D is equal to C times the quantity
a plus C all over B next we need to
figure out some way to calculate the
radius of the circle
the
we can do that is by drawing in this
line segment the line drawn is opposite
a right angle inscribed in the circle
and therefore it must be a diameter of
the circle with length 2 R now we can
use the Pythagorean theorem a squared
plus the quantity B plus d squared is
equal to the quantity 2 R squared and at
this point we need to use algebra to
solve this problem so we first
substitute in D is equal to C times the
quantity a plus C all over B into this
Pythagorean theorem formula we're next
gonna put everything in terms of the
denominator B squared so we have a
common denominator we're then going to
expand everything out and write it as a
single fraction all over B squared now
how are we going to simplify this
expression well look at the first four
terms in this expression we can factor
out a B squared and we get the following
four remaining terms a squared plus B
squared plus two AC plus C squared and
this will simplify to be B squared plus
a plus C the quantity squared now we can
do a similar thing for the next four
terms if we factor C squared from these
we actually get the same resulting
factor so we have C squared times the
quantity B squared plus the quantity a
plus C squared therefore this all
simplifies to be the quantity B squared
plus C squared times this common factor
of B squared plus the quantity a plus C
squared all over B squared and this is
equal to 4 R squared so now we're ready
to solve for R we can divide both sides
by 4 and then we can take the square
root now since R is positive we only
need to consider the positive square
root so finally this is our formula for
R it's the square root of the quantity B
squared plus C squared times the
quantity B squared plus the quantity a
plus C squared all over 2b
did you figure it out thanks for
watching this video these math videos
which can be watched for free on YouTube
inspire and build confidence for people
around the world and they already have
over a 100 million views please
subscribe for free to get the news
videos and email me a puzzle or math
topic pressure and mind your decisions
calm if you so choose you can check out
my merchandise which is listed on
teespring
you can check out my books which are
listed in the video description and you
can support me on patreon for exclusive
rewards thanks for watching and thanks
for your support